yeah welcome to this video beauty well
Kira kion okay let's see what do we got
some nights with Bishop b5 yeah
what-what were playing against that I
have recommended Bishop c5 in my
repertoire series but how is this
working okay let's do something else
check this is always by oops with the
bond interesting yeah Queen takes serve
the normal way to play not too
surprising interesting very active way
to to play
neither try if you might play a form ok
let's go g6
hmm yeah very aggressive play very
aggressive ok let's go for this pseudo
peace sacrifice I need to do something
drastic otherwise I'm probably just just
wiped out in the center ok so we're what
piece do i take yeah probably the bishop
them that son so let's um let's take
stock it's um it's a pawn no it's no
problem but they're okay that doesn't
really doesn't really matter much this
looks like Knight f6 is coming it's not
clear if this is so terrible for black
but what's do I blame
hmm
hard to say okay probably i don't really
not have six me I don't want that but I
wanted to make sure that I have some
some counter play against chanced his
King so that he cannot easily casts a
long he can of course try to to get the
King some meds yeah it's not a big deal
i can play Queen d2 for example
threatening or not not threatening
immediately but getting group takes a
five into the mix of ideas and this is
something that you can probably do in
any case this night easily dominates a
rook yep here we go okay
not sure that this is the best way to
play but what you did I mean but it's
certainly dangerous okay I need to
activate him Queen here prolly castle
slower can take a two if it takes me
seven yahwah then it takes me seven what
can what can I do okay so
how to how to coordinate
tending c5 if he takes her on c7 I play
oopsie age I guess
yeah he's got many pawns so maybe
something even Queen d6 I could be
something now that's not the best way to
go you can just take a seven probably
going to be some okay okay let's attack
c3
oh no this is so simple enter and good
idea probably ok but route du monde
okay here tending rupee for 23 yeah i've
got i have activated the b-team pieces
are not passive anymore yeah I've
returned the capital porns but otherwise
I would have been just a passive okay
sprung
taking is probably not really working
yeah still had some passive play won't
help him check
yeah I can take everything out to our 2
a2 is there something better whoopsie
phone check and why not check yep this
is shiny problem
now you can give this check this is the
big the big issue check check yeah the
check was wasn't to UM to a great as
well
check-check time morning ah what deck
chair lack resides yeah okay I shouldn't
have gone to the end game but I I didn't
really see what what else to do here
it's probably it's probably just not
good spite all the at least a
superficial code to play probably widest
winning all along the Almighty for was
good this retreat I don't I don't yell
and channeled check and the endgame it
it's just too much she's got getting the
rook active and those pawns are strong
yeah so maybe this what the heck maybe
this this whole idea wasn't too great
with taking only for
yeah I can take the night but I don't
watch oh and here I I really gets he get
the night to 12 6 now maybe I need to do
something else here I played played the
caption yeah this was this movie I don't
want to take it forms it's not good
probably maybe two maybe see six and two
should be six or something check yeah
it's not great but let's say I take him
yeah it's so it's still not particularly
great maybe I can play something like
this now possible not i'm not sure what
to do against against the capture of
course I can play this which looks a
more active at first but I wasn't sure
about that because let's say he's doing
something like that 36 it always feels
like at some point that's Bishop h6
coming and I didn't I don't want to sure
this is why i played this more restraint
move no it's a bit bit uncomfortable may
I can I can do this but it's rather nice
for what yeah I'm not sure how to battle
the g takes f three new here it's very
unusual to do but maybe it's possible I
mean obviously it is possible but then
how to play maybe maybe sir
sd-6 is going to play deform it's also
not great yeah maybe Bishop c5 after all
I don't know yeah this wasn't too
successful this Knight takes e4 thanks
for watching